[Music]
have you guys
ever quit a job on bad terms never
never it's always been i'm moving to the
greener grass uh
thank you for the opportunities here i
never quit or got five oh i never got
i never quit on bad terms and i never
got fired same even when i
[ __ ] hated my job i technically got
terminated once i don't know that means
fired
where's their drama that's fired well it
was confusing because i laid off
i worked at a clothing store but i it
was in my hometown but then i went to
college so i wasn't i was never in my
hometown anymore but i would like
randomly come back and do a shift ever
so often
but then they were like you know those
call-in shifts for retail
so i'll call like they wouldn't need me
so cut to like i just never really
worked
even though i was still on the [ __ ]
uh payroll um so one day
i i my friend text me and said hey i
heard the manager is talking about you
getting terminated
uh because apparently you were using uh
the employee discount um
and you weren't even working and i was
like what so i because i hardly ever use
an employee discount i never did
and so someone used your employee
discussion i don't know so then i just
never even addressed it i was like okay
i guess i don't work there anymore
okay i never yeah well because then
apparently i was terminated and i
what if your friend just wanted more of
your hours so she said that and she goes
hey actually cherie says i could have
our hours so what's up yeah
wait so you never spoke to the manager
yeah never no i'm not kidding because i
already i
still hired there so there's no
apparently i'm terminated
i'm just still waiting for her to come
in she calls in for some hours
you know what's crazy i'll i'll tell you
this i just realized this the other
night right
i was chilling by my bed and um i was
it all hit me at once but i was being
sabotaged
and i [ __ ] realized this yesterday i
was working in 2006
right 2006. been on your mind for a long
time what pisses what pissed me off was
like i don't know why
so i was in charge of the inventory for
the whole warehouse right and i kept
getting the count
off and i'm like why the [ __ ] is this
happening right and on top of that
i was pretty much a star player and i
was working my way up
really quick and i think a guy's job was
being threatened
which was my manager it was the first
time he was able to go to vacation
because i came in
but when he came back i think he felt
threatened and then
so he was sabotaging my work because
then uh just the evidence just came up
to my head yesterday and i'm like [ __ ]
man it took me like
almost like 20 years to figure this [ __ ]
out
no i think you figured this out before
because i've heard this before
this is a familiar
you're like you know what i'm gonna
forget this yeah it was off
i would have to talk to the boss of the
company and like he's like man you're
great but i don't know like
you got to be thorough like you there's
mistakes here and i'm like what
how did that happen and then like things
will be shipped to the wrong place and
i'm like
how the [ __ ] did that get shipped there
that's cute there's so much tension in
the workplace you know
that's cute see i'm an honorable worker
right so like when people sabotage my
work like there's so many
games that are being played people make
you look like a bad worker
because they'll [ __ ] your work up
because they don't want to work as hard
if you create a new standard
of how things should be they'll be like
oh [ __ ] well i have to work harder now
too to match
that dude or now he's going to take my
position and i'm just like damn there's
so many games like that being played
it's uh yeah workplaces can be really
really toxic
really really toxic here is a video that
went
super viral of a girl quitting her job
and
oh my god i saw this this is how she
went out [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're
basically
this is how she went out is that a
bottle and i saw her follow up tick
tocks no it's santa claus i haven't seen
those yet it did i mean i'll explain it
i mean it's so small
okay wait is that a battle sriracha in
the back it's santa claus wait what's
going on oh you should start out we
should start over
walmart i love walmart man [ __ ] her and
she said it a couple times
i just wanna say that i just wanna say
that's cool you're cute all walmart
shoppers associates and managers
my name is shawna from cap2 and i just
want to come on here and say
henry is a racist stinky
prank jovana is racist is a prick of a
manager
this company fires black associates for
no reason this company treats their
employees like [ __ ]
especially capture and jimmy from
sporting goods joseph the cashier
larry from garden center you are all
perverts
and i hope you don't talk to your
daughters the way you talk to me
shout out to ariel [ __ ] love you for
getting me this job [ __ ] the managers
[ __ ] this company [ __ ] this position and
[ __ ] that big lazy [ __ ] chris price i
[ __ ] quit damn i felt that
[ __ ] this place love it was people
cheering
did you did you have the videos of the
other angles no i did not get the other
angles there's other people there and
they caught like only like three seconds
of it but
yeah you could see like someone
recording the audio and all the workers
going oh
[ __ ] yeah that's tight that's tough uh
and then her follow-up was
uh she says hey i just want to come on
here because my mom told me
that i need to clear it up that she
didn't raise me to use that type of
language but other than that she's
really proud of me i'm like oh
i have to let y'all know that i'm not
trash because i want to get my mom off
the hook but
[ __ ] walmart she goes that's [ __ ]
right
i didn't teach you that [ __ ] daughter
wow that's [ __ ] right his mom's
cussing at her
why did she just change place where was
this it was this is in
lubbock texas at a walmart yes
yeah i'm trying to see other other
videos i guess they have some racists
and perverts there
can she get in trouble for that after
even though she's quitting
i had an argument with uh a worker at
walmart because i didn't know he was
special
so i came in and i was like hey
uh do you guys have propane here because
i got a propane tank
do you guys do the exchanges he goes you
have uh
yes we sell propane and i'm like all
right where's like
how do i do this and he's like uh do you
have a propane tank and i'm like yeah i
do
and he goes okay what i think you should
do
is you need to get your propane tank and
then we can exchange it and i'm like i
know that's what i
said then i started [ __ ] fighting
with them because that was so fast
well cause i don't know that was very
disgusting because the way he was
telling me
was like i felt like he's calling me a
dumb ass
because he's repeating the same [ __ ]
that i said so it was like
that's what i said i was like why are
you being so [ __ ] sarcastic with me
and i was like and i looked at my friend
and i'm like
oh [ __ ] bro he's just dumb i'm stupid
because i thought that he just two
idiots talking to him
it's like a spider-man meme
[Laughter]
i was like oh [ __ ] ooh i [ __ ] up and
i'm like okay i got it did you have your
hair like that too that would have been
even dope this was
ages ago two idiots wow that's i
i honestly i love it i mean we all
clapped because we were down for it you
know what i mean and we felt it
yeah did she get in trouble i'm not a
fan of [ __ ] like that
like that's not defamation you know we
did a video here
uh about someone quitting over the fact
that she smoked weed like it was a
news anchor or something and she also
she like quit on air
yeah because she was like pro weed
before weed was legal
and she was like pushing for a weed and
she was like you know what i'm out like
she even comes up yeah she said [ __ ]
she didn't [ __ ] this driver's license
wow she got in trouble here's the
video oh yeah that's the one yeah sound
god people please edit like the thing oh
my
are those god these are just oh they're
working it's mixed
yeah but there are ways down that's
crazy
yeah okay i i will say i don't know if i
would have done that route personally
i'm trying to think if
i would ever do that yeah you just
wouldn't show up but right because i
just don't show up
she doesn't even know if she's fired
listen i have apparently i'm
still working on gili hicks well
actually i think they closed i don't
know it was the bronze underwear chain
of abercrombie anyway
um yeah i don't know if i but
honestly if you're really mad like that
[ __ ] might happen like if it was like a
really bad day and i was so triggered by
something that
you know especially if it was like a
privileged white man like you know
telling me this and that
who knows what will happen see the
intercom phone thing then you just grab
it and [ __ ] go off
yeah maybe in the heat of the moment
kind of thing but then like she had
it looked like she had written it down
and she was reading like an award speech
yeah yeah she had to remember who are
all the neat people
that means like she could have addressed
it to hr or like
someone over the manager's head if it
was obviously there was problems with
the manager
and then like if really nothing happened
i felt like that would be my last resort
but that wouldn't have made her viral
maybe she was really strategic about
this you know what i'm saying
that is funny speech there are classier
ways to go
by doing this but at the end of the day
who the [ __ ] is going to look at your
walmart resume
you could pretend that you never worked
there ever no one could get a different
job and get a [ __ ] different job
reference
and to be honest go for it girl do your
[ __ ] if you go to your next job and you
say that there was just like you know
discrimination
and uh sexism etc etc i feel like that's
it
you have to take her word for it you
know and also in terms of going to hr
it's tough boo because the system is
[ __ ] you know what i mean like she
could have gone to hr but they might
have been like
more white privileged men you know what
i mean so it's just hard to
they're protecting the managers at the
end of the day yeah it's almost like she
felt so helpless that no one was gonna
have her back so just [ __ ] it
yeah [ __ ] it i mean there's different
types of people right like if i was in
her shoes
i'm not that type of person so for me
i'd be like i'm [ __ ] out i would tell
my co-workers like hey this is what
happened and i would bounce but
yeah there's people that are down to do
that [ __ ] and those are the ones that
are like [ __ ] yeah they're the crusaders
that's just funny
some of it did seem very personal
obviously when you start throwing like
first and last names out and like going
down department lines and then saying
like i hope you wouldn't talk to your
daughters the way you talk to me like
there may have been certain like things
that like
that people deserve to kind of get put
on blast you know
right honestly like considering like
yeah what she's saying i
like believe her you know what i mean so
it's like she put on the internet so now
homeboy who is you know like
misogynistic or whatever
hopefully his wife sees it and he gets
in trouble you know what i mean
yeah for sure i worked at this place
similar to walmart
let's call it oh there's barget certain
story
with the red polo shirt and i remember
cookies pants khaki pants was the
uniform yeah but
i don't want to put it on blast so we're
going to call it bargain yeah right
it's not what you're thinking about okay
it's not whole foods
okay you said whole foods it's not whole
foods i said coal foods
no no but um i remember i had this
incident with the manager there
um she was really condescending right
and she just [ __ ] got on my nerves
and i had a little bit of problems with
rage back then
and i was a cart technician which means
i collect carts it's a fancy term
right and i remember as soon as she told
me i was like what the [ __ ] and i
grabbed the carts and i got a whole line
of them
and i just ran and charged it as this
as if i was trying to break through the
door and i slammed it through the whole
thing
and then this one asian guy was like hey
you almost ran me over
and i couldn't even say [ __ ] to him and
i just walked off and i got more other
carts and i slammed it against the gate
and i just started slamming more carts
inside and then
they were like joseph we need to talk to
you and i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna get
fired
and i went inside the room and then we
were having a discussion
and then like i was like man she was
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] to me
this and that and then um they're like i
think everyone knew
like what a mean person that manager was
so they were just kind of calm me down
and i didn't get fired
oh that's tight yeah and i was like
thinking i should have gotten fired for
that
did she get hired yeah did she get fired
no i think everyone knew what
okay so she had a problem with uh if she
was frustrated she would
bully the subordinates so that
powertrain they know how
like how she would piss a lot of people
off so
um i think that they were kind of like
well i've never acted that way
and i'm all like always pretty much
stellar so
yeah i feel like i don't know if you
should have gotten fired i don't think
you should have gotten fired because
like you had a
there were people walking back and forth
and i was just like bulldozing the
people
i said an old asian man was like you
almost hit me yeah
you didn't keep going on a tick tock
then if that happened in today's time
you know in the entrance where the carts
are go in
i was just [ __ ] launching carts
inside i think i also kind of have like
an anger issue as well like
maybe still to this day but i remember
just speaking of cards
did you get it dang that was some miyagi
[ __ ] right yeah
but i thought we weren't gonna hurt the
flies anymore because she already lost
her baby oh that was good
that was auntie um but i remember one
time
just speaking of cards i remember uh
because my dad i feel like he really
like liked my cousin better than he
liked me like that's just
well you know we don't need to unpack it
all fully but oh my god it's um
it's his sister my aunt's uh daughter
anyway the point is
i remember once i went at costco and i
was pushing the cart
and then my dad literally was walking uh
with my cousin like in front of me
um and with like his arm around my
cousin like all [ __ ] like as if that
as if she was his [ __ ] daughter and i
got so mad i [ __ ]
pushed the cart and it hit them in the
back that's the worst it hit their
the back of their feet no but here's the
thing so it it was you know costco it
was
it was one of those flat cards it was a
big
big one it hit my dad in the back of the
foot and he like fell
onto it his butt was on something and i
was like oh sorry like i just was so mad
what are you freaking out speaking of
card anger nothing i was like oops or
whatever whatever
it was an accident sorry he's like
that's why i like her more my daughters
are
not i'm [ __ ] to say that
[Music]
wow